So were you kind
of adventurous
when you are growing up, or--
I wanted to be Indiana Jones
when I was younger, but then--
Really?
--I also was super shy.
And were you like, sporty?
No, not at all.
BEAR GRYLLS: So
what, more geeky?
I was super geeky.
BEAR GRYLLS: [laughs]
This is basically my
audition for Indiana Jones.
[laughs] OK.
Let's get into this.
Now this is mangrove swamp.
This is the start of it.
It's actually a pretty
amazing ecosystem,
because it's just so full of
incredible, diverse wildlife.
Lot of crocs, by the way, you
know, further into this stuff.
But this is the start
of the mangrove,
and we need to be
going this way.
It's going to be fun, right?
What's the worst
that could happen?
Yeah, This is going
to be many things.
Fun is not going
to be one of them.
OK.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Whoa-ho-ho.
This, as a survivalist, is good.
God, look at the
size of that one.
Oh, look--
[gasps]
That's a rhino
beetle grub, larvae.
Look at that.
There's another one.
You get that one out.
Oh, my gosh.
Good protein,
good snack, this is.
BEAR GRYLLS (VOICEOVER):
As a general rule,
raw grubs are edible.
They have more protein,
pound for pound, than beef.
And they are plentiful in dark,
damp places all over the world.
But it's critical
that they're purged
before consumption,
in case they've eaten
something poisonous to humans.
BEAR GRYLLS: So
look, grab the head.
No.
And then you just
twist the head, pull
that off, and then all of that.
[laughs] Your face, I love it.
What just fell out of it?
I think some
really medieval guts.
You squeezed his heart out.
Listen, that's many things,
but that's not a heart.
I think that's his anal tract.
[laughing] Ew.
BEAR GRYLLS: [laughs] And
then you're left with that,
and that's all good.
Good energy.
Little skin.
Do you want me to go first,
or do you want to go first?
- I'll do it with you.
- Oh, OK.
Here we go.
I don't think I got
all the anal tract out,
but what's the worst
that could happen, right?
Just adds the flavor.
OK, great.
I just a beetle larva.
I'd rather not explain
what it tastes like.
Ugh.
Doesn't taste very good.
No.
But good energy.
Feel energized, I guess.
Yeah.
I think I'm supposed to feel
more energized than I do.
I think the cappuccinos
work better.